The tubes and
forms are basically
the underlying concept of
HTTP, requests, and responses.
Well, we're not really
going to be shoving paper
through tubes, but rather
data through network cables.
This is what an actual
request looks like.
This is the exact
text the browser
sends to the server to request
an image called kitty.jpg.
Let's dig into the
first line a little bit.
In this case, we are trying to
get a document from the server.
The protocol is also able
to add, delete, and update
documents.
To distinguish between
these capabilities,
the first line starts with
an HTTP method or a verb.
This request uses
the GET method,
which means we want the
server to send data to us.
Another example of
a method is POST,
which instructs the server to
save the data we are sending.
There are more
methods than these,
but we'll worry about them later
when we talked about REST APIs.
Let's get back to
the original request.
After the method, comes the
path and name of the document
we would like to get.
Here, we want the
server to send us
a file called kitty.jpg located
in the pictures directory.
The last thing in the first
line is the version of the HTTP
protocol we are using.
As of today HTTP/1.1 is the
most common and widely supported
version, however HTTP/2 is
slowly catching up and taking
over as the de facto standard.
More on this later.
Surma is now going to show you
the different kinds of headers
an HTTP request can have.